I'm like oh this is sick and then he
pulls out this box this red box
and it's his death row on the box and
he's like open that and I opened it up
and it says big freaking death row
chains giant chain and then he just took
it out of the box and he goes turn
around and he starts putting it on me
and it's like you know I see it he puts
it like he's knighting me right and so
he puts it around my neck and then he's
pulling it up to to to to fasten it
right but when he's pulling it up I
realize like oh [__] like I have a big
so my time by the time he was able to
click it it was already like like a
joker yeah yeah it was about to be like
choker I almost became the guy in the
chair yeah because he pulled it up so
high and then I heard the click click
and I'm like oh God thank you I didn't
think it was gonna click and I heard him
he goes That's what I said
but anyway uh so he put that on me in
the cameras and a big old like yeah yeah
okay don't miss Snoop this weekend blah
blah blah WrestleMania beer man event
and then the guys are like thanks a lot
Snoop thanks love and then they got off
the bus and as soon as they got off the
bus and heard